hello thank you I've been admiring you
from the phone
I'm chilling and you're chilling too cuz
you got your sneaks on girl are we too
close we're really close right now we're
here you're fine
we're up in your grill to do this whole
interview like this I'm down so let's
talk about the fact that the good places
over did you steal anything from the set
I asked for Ted Danson but I was told I
asked for some clothes I got a couple of
clothes
mommy has the best wardrobe ever and
I've asked for some signs from the
neighborhoods which we're gonna be sent
as soon as they take down some of the
set which would be all over my house my
house will soon just be a shrine to Ted
Danson out of the good place who cried
the most Darcy everyone's saying Dorothy
is a tap she's just a human father yeah
because I mean look the show means so
much to all of us I I surprisingly cried
when I said had my season wrap and I'm
English so we don't do that that may
have been a world first for me
I definitely don't crime public and
there would like two hundred people
there but watching Mike walk towards me
and knowing that he took a chance to me
I had no experience as an actor I've
never acted before that audition with
him and for him to give me this role
opposite Ted Danson and Kristen Bell in
one of his new comedies he had no idea
if I'd be able to do what I had to do
and he just took a chance on me made a
decision he's a madman
we should stop him who is gonna make the
blooper reel like the most who do you
think's gonna just kill it this year
it's money money money worked so hard to
fork us up this year during filming he's
got this he makes this terrifying little
face just before about to do a take or
he's like this
and it means that he's about to come up
with something that he's not letting us
in on to break us on camera
apparently there's three minutes of him
to sing one line in a way that is so
funny on a bloopers reel that breaks us
all to the point where Ted cries picky
bride with laughter I can't will it's so
good and then it's probably me saying
disgusting profanities again oh we like
to have a foul mouth
we love that dirty congratulations and
all the Emmy nom I know you're gonna be
going to the Emmys so I want to know
things like who you dating who you're
taking what are you wearing and will you
be wearing the Kylie lip kit I I will be
taking James my boyfriend good yeah a
little bit of arm candy yeah he will be
my date for the evening I don't know
what I'll be wearing but I'm gonna try
and make pay tribute to to honey
that's what I'm gonna do with my outfit
okay yes and I know you got a call from
Megan Marco I did how freaking cool are
you I mean it's just my life is right
now you know me and the Royals thick as
thieves ridiculous ridiculous I didn't
know that she was the guest editor of
Vogue I said why am I on the cover it
was very exciting and so for her to find
me on my own phone in my house was
ridiculous and she was so kind and cool
and warm and personable just we really
give her a hard time in England in the
press and that's we suck because she's
great and no one knows anything about
this human and she's just so graceful
and gracious and takes it on the chin
and just continues to power through on
empowering young women and women of
color and I think she rocks so I'm a fan
thank you awesome shock you have a house
phone god bless